[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa
hablaremos de chile que es el primer
país de américa del sur que ha dado
inicio a la aplicación de la tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
para personas mayores de 55 años con
nuestra corresponsable en la ciudad de
santiago haremos balance de la medida y
también el alcance de la misma porque
servirá de ejemplo para muchos otros
países de la región veremos el caso de
las islas de martinica y guadalupe en el
caribe estos territorios de ultramar
francés han tenido que instaurar
nuevamente la medida de confinamiento
como ya lo hicieron otros territorios
como la isla de la reunión por el rápido
aumento de casos de kobe 19
principalmente debido a la variante
delta y por supuesto va a estar con
nosotros el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 con quien vamos a conversar de
él kobe 19 niños los casos de kobe 19 o
kobe largo también en los menores de
edad y también la incidencia que tiene
el coronavirus y las vacunas en algunos
casos de infertilidad será en sólo unos
minutos comenzamos el programa y lo
vamos a hacer con el balance de la
semana como avanzan los casos y los
fallecidos en todo el continente y en
esta oportunidad nos vamos a enfocar en
la zona del caribe república dominicana
cierra esta semana con más de 345 mil
casos y ya más de tres mil 900 personas
han fallecido en ese país se acercan ya
a las 4.000 víctimas en república
dominicana cuba que hace frente a un
pico de contagio tiene más de 500 mil
casos y más de 3.800 personas han
fallecido hamaika tiene más de 56 mil
casos y más de 1200 personas han perdido
la vida en ese país haití reporta más de
20 mil casos y ya unas 500 personas han
muerto para terminar vamos a esta
trinidad y tobago que tiene más de 41
mil casos confirmados pero un poco más
de 1100 personas han perdido la vida a
lo largo de la emergencia
bueno y vamos a ir ahora con la consulta
con el doctor de carlos eduardo pérez
médico y también médico infectólogo y
asesor científico de france24 doctor
pérez como siempre bienvenido gracias
por acompañarnos en el programa y varios
temas en nuestra agenda de consulta y
comienzo por preguntarle por el kobe 19
en menores de edad todo esto a propósito
del aumento de casos que se están
registrando en eeuu
si una de las cosas que hemos notado es
que en la medida que los grupos
poblacionales mayores primero los
adultos mayores y posteriormente la
gente de 30 años 20 años y ahora la
vacunación de 12 a 16 años que se abrió
en eeuu desplazó a que el número de
contagiados sean los niños recordemos
que los niños generalmente la enfermedad
no produce síntomas o puede producir muy
pocos síntomas y las complicaciones la
vemos en los niños que tienen
comorbilidades como cardiopatías o
alteraciones de sus defensas
inmunodeficiencias y también se acompaña
de un síndrome inflamatorio en algún
grupo de ellos que se ha descrito desde
el brote me di en mi italia y que
también tiene un reconocimiento que
puede suceder dos o tres semanas después
de la enfermedad en la medida que más
adultos se vacunen y los niños no estén
vacunados se va a desplazar este número
de contarles hacia la población infantil
ese bien razón doctor le hemos dicho una
y otra vez a lo largo de toda esta
emergencia sanitaria que esto nos ha
llevado a hacer prueba y error en cuanto
a las investigaciones
para el desarrollo de la vacuna también
en las diferentes áreas que puede
afectar el coronavirus y también los
efectos secundarios que pueden tener
estas vacunas y una de estas áreas de
estudio es la infertilidad ya hay
estudios que indican que en algunos
casos determinados el kobe 19 ha
afectado algunos órganos del aparato
reproductor tanto femenino como
masculino pero que hay de las vacunas
hay reportados algunos casos de personas
que han visto una disminución en su
conteo de esperma otras personas que han
tenido problemas para concebir después
de haber recibido alguna de las dosis de
la vacuna que dice la comunidad
científica
lo primero que tenemos que tener claro
es que lo que produce realmente un daño
en varios órganos es la enfermedad por
kobe si un hombre o una mujer que cuando
tiene un informada por kobe y ésta se
hace es sintomática produce una gran
respuesta inflamatoria recordemos que no
solamente se inflaman los el corazón
pero en el pulmón sino el corazón el
cerebro y todos los órganos de la
economía es al que llamamos tormenta
inflamatoria de citoquinas puede afectar
incluso los órganos genitales y producir
algún tipo de lesión
las vacunas realmente están evaluación
si producen o no alteración han sido más
descripciones sin embargo también hay
muchos factores el solo confinamiento y
situaciones médicas no controladas
porque la gente no está asistiendo a los
medicamentos que también pueden afectar
la fertilidad no hay una relación causal
el que pueda determinar que la vacuna
altera pértiga
por eso las hombres y mujeres podemos y
tenemos que irnos a vacunar con
seguridad
pero el hobby 19 la enfermedad podría
afectar cualquier órgano de la economía
incluyendo el aparato reproductor
femenino y masculino por eso lo más
importante es vacunar nos que no hay
ninguna relación de causalidad con
alteraciones severas en esta en la
reproducción el llamado es a seguir
vacunándose y en caso de que alguna
pareja estuviera en algún tratamiento de
fertilidad puede consultar a la persona
al médico con el que está llevando
adelante este tratamiento doctor para el
cierre de la consulta le pregunto pobre
el commit largo que son estos síntomas
que se mantienen persistentes en algunos
pacientes que han padecido ya el kobe 19
dicen algunos estudios a raíz de lo que
han encontrado el kobe largo que tal vez
el kobe 19 en unos años en el futuro se
convierta en una simple gripa como la
que tenemos habitualmente dependiendo de
las estaciones del año en la que nos
encontremos esto puede llegar a suceder
cuanto le toma el virus volverse
de esta característica y cuánto le
tomara de pronto a la humanidad lograr
tener una inmunidad para poder tener el
kobe 19 como una simple gripa estacional
digamos que hay que distinguir dos cosas
el coi prolongado hace relación a la
persistencia de los síntomas en algún
grupo de personas que puede ser variable
15 20 30 40 por ciento de persistencia
los síntomas más allá de lo usual que
son los 7 o 10 días éste kobe prolongado
es una entidad que estamos aprendiendo
que puede afectar varios órganos y que
en general es una situación reversible
pero en algunos casos pueden persistir
otras otras situaciones que va a pasar
con el virus en el largo tiempo los
coronavirus producen resfriado común
desde hace muchos años estos virus
tienen esa capacidad de ser evolutivos
como lo que estamos viendo las variantes
y algunas variantes aumentan la
transmisión efectiva pero muchas
variantes disminuyen la transmisibilidad
y la contagiosidad es probable que esa
dinámica no la podamos anticipar si
sucederá en cinco o diez años pero
usualmente si nosotros nos vacunamos nos
protegemos completamente se disminuye la
circulación viral y es variantes podrían
ser variantes de menos interés menos
transmisibles para que pueda ser un
virus más de de los por una virus sin
embargo esto es una incertidumbre por
ahora el mensaje muy importante de
santiago para toda nuestra audiencia es
que se sigan vacunando las vacunas
generan confianza y tranquilidad en
nosotros cada vez hay millones de
personas nuevamente vacunadas por vía
que han mejorado sus que han mejorado
notablemente su calidad de salud por eso
no debemos perder la confianza en las
vacunas el llamado y lo hemos reiterado
acá el beneficio que tienen las vacunas
doctor muchas gracias por aclarar estas
dudas reiterar esta información y haber
hecho esta diferenciación entre el cob y
largo y que el kobe 19 en el largo plazo
pueda convertirse de pronto como en una
gripe de las que estamos acostumbrados
pero bueno no hay fecha todavía para eso
muchas gracias doctor por esta consulta
y esta semana comenzó en chile la
aplicación de la tercera dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 más del 70 por
ciento de la población de este país ya
tiene inoculado el esquema completo de
vacunación sin embargo la variante delta
sigue siendo veamos
chile se suma al plan de la tercera
dosis la población de riesgo del país
andino regresó a los centros de
vacunación para obtener una inyección de
refuerzo contra el kobe 19 4 bueno
porque creo que me va a ayudar a ver un
poco más
[Música]
las autoridades chilenas argumentan la
decisión por la amenaza de las nuevas
variantes como la del está frente a la
que los fármacos administrados ven
reducida ligeramente su eficacia todas
las vacunas producen un aumento en los
anticuerpos inicialmente pero pues se
produce una caída sostenida en el tiempo
y los estudios han demostrado que
justamente aproximadamente a los 6 meses
hay una disminución así como chile
uruguay israel alemania rusia y francia
dieron luz verde a la llamada dosis de
refuerzo haciendo oídos sordos a los
llamados de la o ms que pide posponer el
refuerzo hasta finales de septiembre
para que al menos el 10% de la población
mundial sea inmunizada
entiendo la preocupación de los
gobiernos para proteger a su población
de la variante de alta vaclik pero no
podemos y no debemos aceptar que los
países que ya usaron la mayoría de las
reservas de vacunas usen todavía más
using more of it mientras que en el
resto del mundo las personas más
vulnerables continúan desprotegidas and
project ship la organización mundial de
la salud reitera que el principal foco
de aparición de nuevas variantes son las
poblaciones completamente desprotegidas
frente al virus y que en un mundo
globalizado la salud pública es una
cuestión mundial
vamos ahora hasta santiago allí se
encuentra patricia luna que tiene más
información a patricia cuál es el
balance de esta semana de la puesta en
marcha del plan de la aplicación de la
tercera dosis en este país
hola santiago chile comenzó esta semana
a aplicar las dosis de refuerzo también
llamadas tercera dosis a aquella
población mayor de 55 años que hubiera
completado su sistema de inoculación con
la vacuna china sinovac antes del pasado
14 de marzo ha sido una iniciativa muy
bien recibida por la ciudadanía en los
dos primeros días de inoculación a
partir del miércoles cuando se inició ya
se han vacunado más de 155.000 personas
pero también ha causado mucha confusión
entre aquellas personas que querían
acudir a los vacunatorios con una
primera y segunda dosis aquellas
personas que acudían a por una tercera
dosis pero que todavía no están
programadas en el calendario este canto
del en dario continúa la próxima semana
con las personas entre 76 y 55 años en
distintos días de la semana que se
vacunarán antes del 14 de marzo la
segunda quincena de agosto está prevista
para las personas que se vacunaron antes
del 31 de marzo patricia y para el
cierre de este informe cómo está el
panorama general en cuanto a la
vacunación el número de contagiados y
fallecidos allí en chile para el cierre
de esta semana
un momento de bastante tranquilidad con
alguna de las cifras más bajas de toda
la pandemia en las últimas 24 horas se
registraban 882 contagios y una
positividad en todo el país de un 1,4
por ciento con muchas regiones
situándose en un 2 por ciento o menos de
un 2 por ciento de positividad además
los casos han descendido un 16 por
ciento en los últimos siete días y un
30% en los últimos 14 días según los
últimos datos del ministerio de salud
con una población objetivo vacunada de
15 2 millones de personas sobre 19
millones de personas de las que se han
vacunado ya un casi 83 por ciento con
dos dosis y uno casi el 89 por ciento
con una primera dosis se vive un momento
de reapertura por por ejemplo muchos
chilenos pudiendo acudir este fin de
semana por primera vez en ocho estadios
del país para presenciar el fútbol con
público la semana pasada veíamos el
primer concierto masivo en talcahuano
con distancia de seguridad sillas sin
interactuar entre las personas y con
mascarillas sin embargo no hay que
olvidar que la ella se encuentra en el
país según los últimos datos oficiales
son 86 los casos ocho de ellos con
transfusión comunitaria patricia muchas
gracias por este completo informe desde
la ciudad de santiago la capital de
chile y así es como están las cosas en
martinica esta isla de poco más de 374
mil habitantes es un territorio de
ultramar francés en los últimos 28 días
han registrado 15 mil 76 nuevos casos y
los fallecidos en ese mismo período de
tiempo ya alcanzan los 86 martinica
también registra más de 27 mil 800 casos
y 184 personas han fallecido mientras
tanto en guadalupe también en otro
territorio de ultramar francés en el
caribe este territorio de ultramar tiene
más de 400 mil habitantes en sólo 28
días han registrado más de 8.900 nuevos
casos los fallecidos en ese mismo
período de tiempo llegan a 17 mientras
que el total de casos supera ya los 26
mil 700 los fallecidos en guadalupe se
cuentan ya por 291 así es como están las
cosas en este par de islas francesas
una situación sanitaria preocupante en
los dos territorios franceses de
ultramar guadalupe y martinica desde
parís
231 enfermeros y 70 bomberos despegaron
rumbo a las islas en apoyo frente a un
repunte inédito de los contagios de kobe
19 en estos momentos en guadalupe y en
martinica en particular nos enfrentamos
a una situación dramática que reclama la
solidaridad incondicional de toda la
nación un confinamiento estricto fue
decretado en martinica y el mismo
destino le espera a guadalupe donde el
ministro francés de ultramar inició una
visita del martes
desgraciadamente vamos a tener que
reforzar este confinamiento porque
realmente necesitamos frenar la epidemia
aún más rápido
no lo hacemos porque queramos pero es
evidente que debemos proteger a la
población
el personal médico debe verse desbordado
nosotros los médicos y los enfermeros
todos los cuidadores no queremos tener
que elegir entre los pacientes y por eso
luchamos día a día para conseguir abrir
el mayor número de camas posibles pero
desgraciadamente el tamaño de la ola es
tal que no podemos acoger a todos los
pacientes que necesitan cuidados de
reanimación
[Música]
sólo el 22 por ciento de la población
recibió una primera dosis en martinica
donde la variante delta representa el 40
por ciento de los contagios en guadalupe
esta variante representa el 88% de los
contagios o sos un intelectual horner es
en los territorios de ultramar donde se
plantea hoy un escenario urgente de done
si hay que demostrar que la vacunación
es el medio más eficaz para responder a
esta variante del delta manuel no no
desgraciadamente se demuestra cruelmente
en las antillas
que las autoridades esperan que el
confinamiento ayude a frenar la
propagación del virus
pasamos ahora a méxico este país sigue
haciendo frente a la larga tercera ola
de contagio que no dará tregua en ese
país esto mientras también avanza la
vacunación pero tal parece que no es
suficiente para mitigar el impacto de
los contagios mario' carbonell está allí
en ciudad de méxico -mario y gracias por
estar con el programa y comencemos por
las cifras el aumento de los casos
preocupa mucho a las autoridades porque
este pico de contagio pueda prolongarse
mucho más en el tiempo
así es en esta tercera ola se está
rompiendo el récord en esta semana se
alcanzaron las cifras más altas de
contagios reportados en lapsos de 24
horas el pasado miércoles se alcanzaron
los 22 mil 700 casos positivos con lo
que se rompió la barrera de los 3
millones de contagios desde el inicio de
la pandemia para el día siguiente al
jueves fueron casi 25 mil contagios
reportados y mientras tanto por los
hospitales continúan saturándose aquí en
la capital del país lo más importante es
hospitales que atienden padecimientos
respiratorios reportan un cupo casi
total y en este contexto se generó una
controversia porque la secretaría de
salud federal ubicó a la ciudad de
mexico en semáforo epidemiológico color
rojo sin embargo la jefa de gobierno
claudia sheinbaum sostuvo que en la
capital se mantendría en color naranja y
es que el sector económico advirtió que
ya no se aguantaría un nuevo
confinamiento esto sería brutal para la
situación de los empleos ya no es
posible un cierre total de actividades
varios ya lo hablábamos con el doctor
pérez el aumento de los casos de menores
de edad con kobin 19 allí en méxico está
pasando lo mismo llama mucho la atención
que esta franja de la población es la
que está siendo más afectada ahora y
también sigue haya abierto el debate
sobre el posible regreso a las clases
presenciales totales en todos los
estables en todos los estados de la
república mexicana
el subsecretario de salud hugo lópez
gatell ha aclarado que no hay sustento
para afirmar que está tercera ola le
esté pegando más a los niños ya los
jóvenes y dice que el índice de
mortalidad se mantiene bajo lo cual es
cierto sin embargo la hospitalización de
menores de edad se ha incrementado en
200 por ciento al menos en la capital
del país y esta situación se presenta en
otros estados en la ciudad de mexico hay
5000 casos activos de menores de 0 a 17
años y a pesar de ello el gobierno del
presidente de lópez obrador insiste en
la vuelta a clases presencial la
secretaría de educación pública definió
lineamientos entre ellos que los padres
firmen una carta responsiva en la que se
comprometen a monitorear los signos de
los pequeños detectar cualquier posible
síntoma de covite y de ser el caso no
mandarnos a la escuela y no enviarlos y
llevarlos al doctor y reportar el
diagnóstico médico no obstante esta
vuelta a clase presencial tiene carácter
voluntario así se acordó con los estados
por lo que pues ya veremos en realidad
cuántos niños vuelven
-mario muchas gracias por este reporte
desde ciudad de mexico importante lo que
está sucediendo allí con esta tercera
ola que no da tregua y también en eeuu
siguen presentando allí incrementos
rápidos en el número de casos y de
hospitalizaciones allí por cuenta de la
variante delta de kobe 19 si bien el
estado de florida es donde se está
registrando el mayor número de contagios
y hospitalizaciones california con más
de 4 millones de casos sigue siendo el
estado más crítico en toda la unión
americana le sigue texas con más de 3.3
millones de casos luego está florida
también en el sur del país con más de
2.7 millones de casos georgia con más de
1.2 millones de casos registrados y
finaliza este top 5 luisiana con más de
600 mil casos registrados así es como
están las cosas en eeuu
[Música]
en eeuu el kobe 19 no da tregua expertos
atribuyen el aumento en los contagios a
la animadversión a la vacunación de
algunos ciudadanos el incremento en el
número de contagio está atribuido
principalmente a la variante de alta
entiendo que hay personas decididas
adultos que decidieron no va a
personarse y no tener
para usted
pero también entiendo que la razón por
la que los niños se infectan es porque
la mayoría de ellos viven estados y
comunidades donde las tasas de
vacunación son bajas y se infectan por
adultos no vacunados eso es lo que está
sucediendo
and sociable según el 'new york times'
de las personas vacunadas sólo han
llegado al hospital un máximo del 5 por
ciento por otro lado sólo el 6% ha
fallecido
a
hemos abierto más de 5 unidades que
están dedicadas a los pacientes con ccoo
y 19 esto ha sido un gran cambio puesto
que antes atendíamos a 20 o 30 y hoy hay
más de 189
el último conteo independiente de la
universidad johns hopkins señala que la
unión americana se mantiene como la
nación más afectada con más de 36
millones de contagios y 168.000 86
muertes asociadas a la enfermedad
vamos ahora a las cifras de vacunación
para el cierre de esta semana veamos
puntualmente el número de dosis
inoculadas en diferentes países de
américa latina en cuanto a las dosis
aplicadas el país es líder es méxico
mire nomás
74.8 millones de dosis aplicadas en este
país le sigue argentina con más de 36
millones de dosis en tercer lugar está
colombia con más de 31 millones de dosis
ya aplicadas chile ha inoculado más de
26.5 millones de dosis y cierra este top
pero con más de 15.6 millones de dosis
inoculadas
y cuba también está haciendo frente a
una ola de contagio que deja promedios
diarios de 8000 casos nuevos por día la
variante de esta tiene al borde del
colapso del sistema de salud de ese país
y por este motivo muchos doctores que
hacen parte de las misiones médicas
internacionales cubanas en el exterior
han regresado para dar un refuerzo al
sistema de salud mientras que la
diáspora ha enviado medicinas
cuba sufre un pico pandémico por la
variante delta con un incremento de
miles de casos diarios desde semanas a
pesar de contar con un plan de
vacunación que ya inmunizó a más del 60%
de la población y dos vacunas producidas
localmente soberana y abdalá el sistema
de salud cubano se encuentra sobrepasado
tenemos bastante fallecido una
institución y que tenemos una sola
morgue que tenemos un solo crematorio y
que son muchos fallecidos el presidente
de cuba miguel díaz-canel mencionó los
esfuerzos que se realizan para enfrentar
la pandemia y pidió hacer un esfuerzo a
la población les pido comprensión
compromiso y pensamiento sobre todo para
en el menor tiempo posible estar en las
condiciones para sobrepasar este pico
pandémico que podemos vencer señal de la
agudeza de la situación cientos de
doctores cubanos que se encontraban en
misiones en diferentes países regresaron
a la isla para brindar apoyo en
hospitales si bien cuba mantuvo los
casos de kobe bajo control durante el
primer año de la pandemia la variante
delta cambió esta situación
los casos que surgen a partir de la de
la cepa delta que es una cepa más
expansiva de una cepa más
agresiva indiscutiblemente que nos está
creando situaciones complejas a nivel de
a nivel hospitalario
también desde el extranjero llegan
medicamentos para aliviar la escasez de
productos de salud muestra de la
solidaridad de la diáspora cubana el
gobierno cubano que enfrenta el pico
pandémico con un embargo de eeuu y en
temporada de huracanes llamó al personal
de salud acelera los procesos de
vacunación suministros de oxígeno y
medicamentos
y para comparar como esta suramérica y
en general el continente americano
veamos esta comparación del porcentaje
de la población vacunada con la dosis
completa es decir el esquema completo de
vacunación
europa es el continente líder con el 42
punto 88 por ciento le sigue américa del
norte que hace parte de nuestro
continente pero pues lo hemos dividido
así con el 39 punto 32 por ciento sigue
sudamérica en tercer lugar con 23 puntos
29 por ciento de la población ya con el
esquema completo oceanía las islas del
pacífico alcanzan 14 puntos 64 por
ciento asia que es el continente origen
del corona virus que produce el cob y 19
allí solamente el 12 punto 27 por ciento
de la población tiene el esquema
completo mientras que áfrica está con
2.08 por ciento esto sin tener en cuenta
que ya muchos países han comenzado a
aplicar una tercera dosis como parte de
un esquema completo de vacunación
vamos ahora hasta brasil para conocer
los detalles qué novedades hubo a lo
largo de la semana en este país les
cuento la primera es una reducción
significativa de las cifras a nivel
nacional lo que ha dado una especie de
respiro al sistema de salud y también a
los brasileños los detalles los tiene
valeria saccone desde la ciudad de río
de janeiro la valeria gracias por estar
con nosotros en el programa y hablemos
de esa disminución de las cifras da
cierta tranquilidad ya un poco este
respiro que da la pandemia en brasilia
en brasil la vacunación avanza pero a
trompicones en los telediarios vemos
ciudades como río de janeiro y san pablo
que tienen que interrumpir de vez en
cuando el ciclo de vacunación por falta
de dosis que llegan a cuentagotas sin
embargo se avanza ya son 160 millones
los brasileños que han recibido la
primera dosis es decir el 53 por ciento
de una población enorme brasil es el
país más poblado del continente y tienen
212 millones de habitantes se sabía
desde el principio que iba a ser un reto
enorme vacunar a toda esta enorme
población
48 millones de brasileños es decir el 23
por ciento de la población ha recibido
las dos dosis y está totalmente
inmunizada y por eso estamos viendo que
baja lentamente las cifras de muertos
hay que decir que también las
restricciones son cada vez menores
todavía es obligatorio llevar la
mascarilla a algunos estados de los 27
que componen esa federación todavía
limitan el horario de apertura de
algunos bares son las fiestas nocturnas
pero por ejemplo río de janeiro donde me
encuentro hace meses que cualquier
persona que viene aquí creería que la
pandemia se ha acabado cosas que no hay
cierta incluso el alcalde de río de
janeiro eduardo paes había anunciado a
bombo y platillo una fiesta a principios
de septiembre de cuatro días para poder
celebrar la vuelta a la normalidad luego
ha dado marcha atrás ha dicho que habrá
que ver las los datos de contagio cómo
avanza la variante delta y todavía no
sabremos si hay esta fiesta pero lo que
sí se respira es un área de normalidad
en una ciudad que nunca se ha tomado muy
en serio la pandemia normalidad entonces
allí en río de janeiro valeria para el
cierre de este reporte entonces el
panorama general en cuanto a los casos
de contagiados y fallecidos a nivel
nacional y las restricciones que se
mantienen también en otros estados
brasil por fin comienza a respirar nunca
mejor dicho hay una buena noticia fruto
de la vacunación en el mes de julio el
30 por ciento de las ciudades brasileñas
es decir 1750 municipios no registraron
ninguna muerte por el hobbit 19 además
en el 63 por ciento de las ciudades de
brasil también hay una baja importante
en el número de fallecidos hay que decir
que las últimas dos semanas la media
diaria se ha quedado por debajo de las
mil víctimas mortales sigue siendo mucho
pero es mucho menos que los datos que
vimos por ejemplo en abril cuando
llegamos a picos de 4300 muertos diarios
parece que brasil entra por fin en una
fase de estabilidad aunque la varianza
delta sigue preocupando ya está presente
en 14 estados de brasil y se teme que
pueda causar una tercera ola
gracias valeria por este reporte desde
la ciudad de río de janeiro seguimos en
el continente suramericano argentina
anunció oficialmente el inicio de la
producción de la vacuna rusa sputnik ve
en un laboratorio local
argentina es ahora el primer país
sudamericano en producir localmente la
vacuna rusa sputnik ve en medio de las
demoras presentadas en las últimas
semanas con la llegada de la segunda
dosis del componente ruso el gobierno
argentino recibió con satisfacción las
primeras vacunas producidas en la nación
muy contentos por haber recibido del
laboratorio richmond una tarea que se
vino llevando adelante
durante meses y meses de trabajo y hoy
culmina con la entrega para el
ministerio de salud y la posterior
distribución de las vacunas hechas en
argentina
para hacer posible la producción el
antígeno se importa de rusia de modo que
el proceso de formulación filtrado
envasado y finalmente los controles de
calidad para la liberación del producto
serán realizados en el país sudamericano
el laboratorio richmond entregó
novecientos noventa y cinco mil 125
dosis del primer componente y 152 mil
500 dosis del segundo de la vacuna
sputnik bay producida en las
instalaciones de la compañía
sputnik de fue la primera vacuna kobe 19
que llegó a argentina en diciembre de
2020 tras un acuerdo con el gobierno
ruso de unos 30 millones de dosis
se espera que el laboratorio richmond
responsable de la fabricación local
elabora al menos 3 millones de dosis del
segundo componente con miras a
solucionar el retraso en el programa de
vacunación de este país del cono sur nos
vamos hasta uruguay las novedades pasan
por una leve reducción también allí de
los casos karina de almas en la ciudad
de punta del este nos va a contar cuál
es el balance de la vacunación en los
jóvenes para iniciar este informe desde
uruguay
uruguay inició la vacunación a menores
de 18 años en junio actualmente el 70%
de aquellos que se registraron
voluntariamente ya han recibido al menos
una dosis del laboratorio facer en los
últimos días se volvió a reabrir la
polémica en cuanto a la inmunización de
menores y es que dos adolescentes uno de
12 y otro de 14 años sufrieron de
miocarditis una inflamación en el
músculo cardíaco las autoridades
sanitarias insistieron en la seguridad
de la vacuna dicen que los casos son más
graves cuando contraen el kobe 19 y
justamente pueden estar expuestos a la
miocarditis pero en forma severa
señalaron además que ocurrieron dos
casos luego de un millón de dosis de la
vacuna facer en uruguay lo mismo dijo la
sociedad uruguaya de pediatría quienes
además insistieron en que los
adolescentes sean vacunados porque lo
consideran una población riesgo y
quienes pueden sufrir el kobe de ese 19
de manera muy severa karim hay en
uruguay también comenzaron a disminuir
un poco las cifras que dicen allí
hace dos meses uruguay era el país con
mayor cantidad de muertes diarias en el
mundo en relación a su población
actualmente la situación es muy distinta
se están registrando un promedio semanal
de 6 muertes por día muy diferente a las
60 muertes diarias que ocurría en el mes
de junio esto es debido a una intensa
campaña de vacunación según indican los
expertos quienes analizan la tendencia
mejorable que está viviendo uruguay en
estos momentos dos tercios de la
población ya ha recibido al menos una
dosis contra el cob y 19 y el 66% ya
está totalmente
inmunizado al recibir dos dosis de la
vacuna sin embargo las autoridades están
también muy atentos porque la variante
delta ya está en el país y se está
desplazando dentro del mismo por lo cual
están ofreciendo una tercera dosis de
vacunación como refuerzo a aquellos que
hayan ya recibido dos dosis en este caso
es del laboratorio facer para aquellos
que se hayan vacunado con la del
laboratorio sinovac
karina gracias por este reporte desde
uruguay este país también abrirá las
fronteras a partir del mes de noviembre
para personas vacunadas procedentes de
otros países es todo por el momento aquí
en kobe 19 la semana en américa nos
vemos la próxima semana con más noticias
destacadas de la pandemia kobe 19 en
nuestro continente siga cuidándose por
favor y sigan viendo france24
[Música]